Noah Cyrus in tears after her ex lil zan
announces he's going to be a dad yeah
blows and revealed his fiancee Annie
Smith is pregnant with their first child
sharing this pic caption it's official
I'm going to be a father I've never felt
more happy in my life all of you are
invited to the gender-reveal party
I promise which has us all thinking
about his ex Noah Cyrus because the same
day Noah posted this crying selfie honor
in story that read what a day later
sharing a less emotional pic on her page
caption I will be happy if it's the last
thing I do and they kind of broke up a
little recently it was like the end of
last year last summer
yes I'm sure there's still some emotions
there and obviously she's just trying to
get through her day like all of us but
of course the timing seems like a
coincidence fans are quick to point out
that the two posts seem like they may be
about each other yeah many critics even
calling out the 22-year old rappers
fiance for making the announcement too
soon at just 5 weeks along and he set
the record straight on why her man
couldn't wait to share the baby news she
initially wanted to wait until after her
12-week mark Annie Road yes this was
planned Diego and I have had baby names
picked out for months already started at
wedding planning and have been trying to
get pregnant now let's recap Noah and
little Sam's relationship which was
brief but sloppy that's his word not
ours yeah of course they made their
couple debut at the MTV VMAs less August
and seemed crazy in love but a few weeks
later they aired their breakup all over
social media he accused her of cheating
with like this Charlie puth meme it was
really weird which she denied and then
two weeks later our own Kate cross Thank
You Katie I snow up what happened we saw
you in August with your then boyfriend
lil van at the VMAs you guys look so in
love spot fast forward to a few weeks
later what happened and how are you
doing I'm fine yeah totally fine you
seem fine yeah I think it's just
something that we both will move on from
and it's all love it's all good
you know I'm confused that's all I'm
gonna say is I'm confused but that's
cool I mean what why are you confused I
did it's just it was a shock for
everybody I think I didn't know what's
gonna happen
this isn't honestly there's no point in
drama really great because EP meets a
sign there's no like I'm just like I
just gotta focus on me right now and I
don't really need to have a boyfriend
right now anyways and I realized that
when everything blew up in my face like
Noah just take a time to take the time
to work on yourself and make yourself
happy yeah and you don't need a man to
make you happy though that's for all of
you girls out there you do not need a
guy to make you happy that's for sure
of course we'll keep you updated with
all the latest on noah and lows and so
be sure to subscribe to all things ET I
met Courtney underscore tez know and I'm
a - crossing bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]